مع استمرار الفظائع التي ارتكبها بوتين في
أوكرانيا ، فإنه يلقي باللوم على الغرب
وأوروبا في الحرب التي
يدفعها الكوكب بأسره الآن مقابل
طموحات الغرب ومحاولات الغرب
للحفاظ على هيمنته المراوغة ، ومع ذلك
فإن بناته البالغات اللائي فرضت عليهما عقوبات من قبل
وزارة الخزانة الأمريكية ، ملكتا
ممتلكات.  في الغرب بما في ذلك
هذا القصر
الساحلي في بلدة بياريتز الساحلية الفرنسية ، من
النفاق السخرية من الغرب
وقيمهم الليبرالية ثم الاعتماد
على الغرب وقيمهم الليبرالية
التي يتقاسمها النفاق الذي ينتقد الغرب
بينما يعيش أفراد الأسرة في الغرب.
الدائرة المقربة
لبوتين ، السكرتير الصحفي في الكرملين ، ديمتري بيسكوف ،
يتمثل الدور غير الرسمي لفلاديمير بوتين في أن
الجيش الروسي
الكاذب لا يضرب
أهدافًا مدنية مدنية قضى
حياته في الوظائف الحكومية براتب المسؤولين
حوالي 173 ألف دولار في عام 2020 ، ومع
ذلك تم رصده وهو يرتدي ساعة 600000
وفقًا لـ  مجموعة لمكافحة الفساد
ذهبت ابنته الاجتماعية ليزا إلى
الصعود  مدرسة في فرنسا تدربت في
لويس فويتون ونشرت صوراً
لحياة تحسد عليها في باريس مليئة
بالأزياء والسحر
أنا أعتبر نفسي شخصًا من العالم الذي
ولدت في تركيا أعيش في فرنسا
درست في روسيا في فرنسا وهذا
ليس لدي أي شيء  البلد المفضل ، أنا أحب
كل مكان بطريقته الخاصة ، فكيف
تعيش عائلة مثل هذا على
راتب حكومي روسي ، كتبت ليزا بيسكوفا ذات مرة تعليقًا ساخرًا
تقول فيه
إنها ابنة الملياردير الرئيسي
ولص الخزانة الأمريكية  جميعهم استخدموا نفس
اللغة عندما فرضوا عقوبات عليها
وأفراد عائلتها الآخرين قائلين إنهم يعيشون
أنماط حياة فاخرة
تتعارض مع
راتب موظف الخدمة المدنية لبيسكوف ومن المحتمل أن تكون مبنية
على الثروة غير المشروعة لعلاقة
بيسكوف ببوتين باسكوفا التي وصفت
العقوبات بأنها مطاردة ساحرة  برقية
تقول إن اتهام العائلة بتمكين الحرب
هو جنون وهي فخورة
بكونها أستاذة جامعية روسية جودي فيتوري جورجتاون
متخصصة في الدولة غير المشروعة
يقول التمويل إنه يتلخص في نظام kleptocracy الحالي في روسيا ،
فإن kleptocracy هي مجرد
حكومة يحكمها اللصوص وحيث تكون
السياسات والقرارات المتخذة
نيابة عن هؤلاء اللصوص ، إنها قصة مماثلة
لوزير الخارجية الروسي سيرجي لافروف الذي
يربح رسميًا 142
ألف دولار  عام لكن الفتاة
البالغة من العمر 27 عامًا والتي
وصفتها الحكومة البريطانية بأنها ابنة لافروف
كانت تعيش أسلوب حياة فخم
اسمها باولينا كوفاليفا ، وهي
مؤسسة مكافحة الفساد ، تقول إنها
التحقت بمدرسة داخلية بريطانية مثل
ابنة بيسكوف التي تركت أثرها على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي.  رحلات غريبة مغامرات غنية قذرة
وأسلوب راق عبر أوروبا
وخارجها ويقال إنها تمتلك
عقارًا بقيمة 4 ملايين جنيه إسترليني في لندن
وفقًا للمملكة المتحدة حيث تمت
معاقبتها لاستفادتها من
ارتباط أولئك المسؤولين عن
العدوان الروسي على الرغم من أن المحاسبة
يكاد يكون من المستحيل تتبع الروسية
ماريا محققة مكافحة الفساد
بيبسيا مقتنعة بأن
أنماط حياة القصور هي
الرواتب الحقيقية التي تُدفع لحلفاء بوتين ،
فإن النظام يعمل بطريقة من
أجل الحفاظ على هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين هم
على استعداد ليكونوا وجهًا
للنظام البريطاني مثل الوزراء الذين يحتاجون
إلى تحفيزهم.
الراتب ليس كافيًا
تقول جودي فيتوري من جورجتاون إن الأشخاص في
الدائرة المقربة لبوتين يعرفون أنه يمكن أن يختفي جميعًا في
لحظة يمكنه تشغيل أي من
نظامه في أي وقت ، لذلك يختار ممتلكاتك
ويمكن تجميدها يمكنك الذهاب إلى السجن حيث
يمكن لعائلتك الذهاب  إلى السجن ، قد
تجد نفسك مطاردًا ، لذا فإن الانتقال
قدر المستطاع
خارج البلد أمر منطقي